bonsoir mes chaises au décours merci
d'être avec nous que vous inspire tout
d'abord ces incidents une pluie de
débris sur le trip de sept au départ de
denver et puis sur les pays-bas des
débris cette fois ci du 747 400 beaucoup
plus vieux bien sûr mais est ce normal
que les avis vont les avions tombent en
miettes au dessus de nos têtes
normal que les avions tombent en miettes
au dessus de nos têtes
d'ailleurs ça n'est pas le cas en fait
de temps en temps hélas des moteurs se
détruisent envol c'est arrivé plusieurs
fois vous avez vu le cadre ce boeing 747
anciens mais c'est arrivé en fait ces
dernières années ces dix dernières
années sur les trois très gros modèles
d'avions plutôt de moteur qui existent
dans le monde
c'est arrivé sur un airbus a380 de la
qantas en 2010 avec un moteur rolls
royce
c'est arrivé sur un airbus a380 d'air
france en 2010 7 avec des moteurs engine
alliance c'est à dire general electric
et pratt & whitney et là ça arrive avec
un moteur pratt & whitney 4077 sur un
boeing 777
en fait on sait maintenant depuis
quelques mois je peux dire que il y a
des problèmes de fatigue de métal sur
les très gros moteurs d'avion le bureau
d'enquêtés et d'analysés français a fait
une étude très intéressante à l'occasion
de l' enquête qui a été fait sur ce qui
s'était produit au dessus du groenland
avec un vol d'air france et ils ont
découvert un phénomène qu'on appelle la
fatigue douelle et qui est en fait un
phénomène de dégradation des métaux
précieux comme le titane qui est
utilisée parce qu'il est extrêmement
résistant et peu lourd et qui avec le
temps peut se dégrader notamment
provoqué des dégradations des pales or
les pales vous le savez tourne à des
vitesses très élevées
un moteur d'avion ça tourne autour de 20
mille tours à peu près la minute et donc
lorsqu'une pale se brise se détache ça
provoque des dégâts qui normalement
doivent être contenues par le moteur
c'est d'ailleurs comme ça que les
moteurs sont certifiés mais on a vu
aussi bien pour le vol de qantas que le
vol d'air france que pour ce vol qu'il
ya quand même des débris qui ne sont pas
convenues et c'est très ennuyeux
oui oui alors michel comme j'allais dire
là vous êtes en train de terroriser tous
les gens qui ont déjà peur de l'avion ce
phénomène d'usure des métaux est ce que
c'est un phénomène récent et seront
fabrique des avions de moins bonne
qualité aujourd'hui où ça n'a rien à
voir ça a toujours existé sauf peut-être
alors en fait si vous voulez les
problèmes de fatigue du métal toujours
existé simplement avec le temps on a
fait des progrès considérables en
matière de travail sur les métaux et de
traitement des métaux aussi bien lors du
de la fabrication du coulage que de
l'usinage et c est penser que sur les
très très gros moteur moteur qu'il faut
le rappeler tourner quelques fois
pendant 15 17 heures 18 heures par jour
voire plus
on était à l'abri de problèmes de
fatigue de métal parce qu'on avait mis
des métaux comme le titanic est un métal
rare et qui est assez léger en quantité
assez importante pour pouvoir supporter
les charges et les efforts qui sont qui
se produisent lors de ces vols sur les
très très gros moteurs encore une fois
je le dis et donc sur les très très gros
avion et on a vécu comme ça quelques
années je dirais confortable et puis
maintenant on découvre avec le temps que
en fait il ya des phénomènes qui n'ont
pas été connus qui ne se détecte pas
facilement lors des inspections et qui
peuvent se produire alors ça s'est
produit
en fait sur les trois accidents que je
vous ai cités ça s'est produit deux fois
donc c'est pas énorme quand on compare
aux 40 millions de vols se font chaque
année avec des avions de ligne mais
c'est quand même toujours trop parce que
un jour ça peut déboucher sur un
accident grave
voire mortelles heureusement pour
l'instant ce n'est pas ce qui s'est
produit
mais les laboratoires car hélas il
s'agit vraiment de laboratoire des
producteurs de métaux travaille là
dessus les constructeurs de moteurs
travaille là dessus évidemment les
constructeurs d'avions dépend totalement
de et pour l'instant ce qu'on fait c'est
qu'on multiplie les contrôles on les
rend beaucoup plus fréquent de manière à
pouvoir détecter tout tout risque de
défaillance
et cette formule apparemment est
suffisant simplement sur le boeing 777
200 ou 300 équipés des moteurs pratt &
whitney 4077 eh bien on n'était pas très
méfiants parce que c'est un avion qui a
trente ans maintenant et que donc ces
moteurs sont des moteurs très éprouvés
et qu'on ne pensait pas que ça allait se
produire à l'image là vous avez un mode
un avion très particulier c'est le jumbo
de boeing qui sert à transporter les
morceaux d'avion
ce n'est pas un avion de 10 alors 735,8
tout à fait 737 max 1 c'était l'avion
qui avait été interdite de vol en mars
2010 neuf après deux accidents on se
souvient qu'il avait fait 346 mort on
rajoute à cela
effectivement la crise sanitaire et ces
derniers incidents sur le triple sept
est-ce que clairement ça peut être
vraiment une très mauvaise passe vous
voir la fin pour boeing ou c'est un peu
prématuré la fin de bail il n'en est pas
question baux signés du temps dans une
entreprise immense qui travaillent dans
le domaine militaire spatial civil et
qui a de très nombreuses activités même
si aujourd'hui elle à 60 milliards de
dollars de dettes
même si l'année dernière elle a perdu 20
milliards de dollars essentiellement à
cause de la crise du boeing 737 max on
va dire que boeing n'est pas en danger
de disparaître
maintenant la division avions civils de
boeing traverse une passe très très
difficile comme le dit
certaines célébrités françaises les
emmerdements volent toujours en
escadrille
et c'est vrai que pauline ya eu des
soucis avec à peu près tous ses modèles
depuis deux ans soit des problèmes de
cellules soit des problèmes de moteur ce
que des problèmes lors des essais en vol
etc etc et que tout cela combiné fait
que ben oui en ce moment produit avec la
crise bien sûr en plus ce produit très
très peu d'avions ils en produisent
entre deux et trois fois moins qu airbus
et deuxièmement leurs avions sont des
avions qui pour une bonne part sont des
avions anciens qui ont été rénovés
plusieurs fois et qui donc sont
évidemment pas les vedettes du marché
donc boeing est en situation délicate
même si c'est une entreprise qui
fabrique des très bons et très beaux
avions mais son catalogue commence à
dater
et il est vrai que boeing a besoin d'une
très sérieuse reprise en main merci
michel polacco d'avoir été avec nous à
voir apporter votre expertise